good morning everybody it is at seven
o'clock you're very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on sky news
this morning it's absolutely packed
starting with the prime minister facing
calls to resign this morning from all
sides three opposition leaders want him
gone and eight of his own mps following
his party gate fine but will saying
sorry multiple times be enough to save
him we'll ask the minister for small
business paul scully who's on the show
shortly and get reaction from the deputy
labour leader angela raynor and the
smp's westminster leader ian blackford
plus the conservative mp who was the
first to publicly confirm he'd submitted
a letter of no confidence in the pm sir
roger gail
also this morning joined by the u.s
interim ambassador to the uk philip t
recap to get his views on what's
happening here plus the fight for
eastern ukraine it's wednesday the 20th
of april
sitting uncomfortably at least eight
conservative mps now want the prime
minister to resign following his
partygate performance in the commons
it did not occur to me then
or subsequently that a gathering in the
cabinet room just before a vital meeting
on covet strategy
could amount
to a breach of the rules
the battle for donbass russia takes one
city but ukrainian forces repel other
attacks we report from the trenches in
the region
well we're just approaching the small
town of piske and it's right on the
front line the russian
soldiers are a kilometer or two ahead of
us
i'm live in the capital kiev where the
president has renewed a plea for more
western weapons to help fend off the
russian offensive
i'm at buckingham palace as prince harry
reveals details of his and megan's
secret meeting with the queen explosive
revelations as johnny depp denies ever
hitting a woman as he gives testimony in
his libel case against his ex-wife amber
hood
one day you're
cinderella so to speak and then in 0.6
seconds you're
quasimodo
[Music]
oasis rocker liam gallagher opens up
about his health saying he'd rather use
a wheelchair than have a hip operation
also coming up on the program for you
this morning wherever you're watching us
around the world we head to the
philippines and speak to the travel
editor for the telegraph as tourism
chiefs meet there for the first time
since covid to discuss how to help the
sector recover
[Music]
and an anthem for the queen's platinum
jubilee joined by the leading lady
leslie garrett later in the programme
[Music]
morning everybody multiple apologies
multiple calls to resign the prime
minister under pressure this morning
following his partygate explanation to
mps in the commons yesterday three
opposition leaders calling for him to
quit
sky news understands now at least eight
conservative mps
the most recent is the former commons
chief whip and that's uh mark harper you
probably heard him in the comments
yesterday he actually submitted a letter
of no confidence in the prime minister
also on the list is the former defense
minister tobias elwood nigel mills the
mp for the amber valley and craig
whittaker the mp for calder valley he
said the pm should do the right thing
and resign the other four are caroline
knox mp for ramsey and southampton north
gary street of the mp for southwest
devon anthony magnull mp for top ness
and peter alders the mp for waveney
as soon as i received the notice
i acknowledged the hurt
and the anger
and i said that people had a right
to expect better
of their
prime minister
and i repeat that mr speaker again
in the house now
let me also say
not by way
of mitigation
or
excuse me
but purely
purely because it explains my previous
words in this house
that it did not occur to me then
or subsequently that a gathering in the
cabinet room just before a vital meeting
on covet strategy
could amount
to a breach of the rules
i repeat
that was my
mistake
and i apologize for it
unreservedly
the more people debase themselves
parroting his absurd defenses
the more the public will believe all
politicians are the same all as bad as
each other
and that suits this prime minister just
fine
some members opposite seem oblivious to
the prime minister's game
some know what he's up to
but are too weak to act
but others are gleefully playing the
part the prime minister cast for them
a minister on the radio this morning
saying
it's the same as a speeding ticket
no it's not
minister representing the government
this morning paul scully is with us good
morning thank you for joining us um the
former chief whip the man responsible
for making sure that back benchers did
what they were supposed to do and
support boris johnson is now saying that
boris johnson is not worthy of the
office of prime minister why do you
think he is
uh look i respect mark harper's uh views
on this and other other um uh
backbenchers that have taken there come
to their own conclusions the prime
minister has uh made a full statement
yesterday he
made a full apology yesterday as well he
was under the belief uh at that time
that uh that uh what what he did was it
acceptable in terms of he was with the
same people that he was going to be
within in the meeting afterwards
um and was probably working with before
but nonetheless the police have um uh
have come to that different conclusion
he absolutely respects that and i think
it's the right thing to do for him to
make that apology to pay the fine and
then get get back to the day job those
really important okay
here's the thing then what if he's so
confident that he's you know doing the
right thing why doesn't he allow the um
privileges committee
to decide whether or not he has broken
any rules why doesn't he just say full
disclosure you can look at whatever you
like well i think there's a number of um
procedures in place at the moment in
terms of the met police investigation is
still going on because there's other
events being investigated sugree has
been charged with uh publishing the full
report uh the the the after having done
her interim report a few weeks ago and
so there's a number of um uh streams of
process already in in in action but
we'll see what happens with the motion
why doesn't he allow his colleagues to
look at that he's got nothing
they will be able to see that but you
know from that sue grey report they'll
see that they'll see all the detail
there rather than setting up a third
strand of investigation but we'll see
what happens at um uh tomorrow in the in
the debate in parliament tomorrow is it
because uh uh as according to jacob
jacob reese moga should say that the
privilege
i'll say that again the privileges
committee is a distinguished body but
it's chaired by a labour party
politician i'd bear that
in mind what does he mean by that i
don't know that's not that's certainly
not the you know the he doesn't have a
point well that's not the view that i
take i mean the the the point is as i
say there was a number of strands of uh
uh investigation into this whole
situation and rather than start another
strand at this point in time i think we
need to exhaust those those processes
yesterday he was at the dispatch box and
he apologized and he apologized and he
apologized i think 30 times something
like that but only about one incident
and he's only been fined for one
incident at the moment but as we all
know he's being um investigated for six
separate events how many times
does a prime minister have to break the
law before he has to step down i think
well first of all i can't speculate on
the investigation that's carried on
because the events i know that but i
think that what we need to do is look at
each of those events in the round there
may be different circumstances there may
not be i don't know there may be the
similar there's a similar uh view
similar defense that the prime
minister's taking in terms of the the he
believed it was within a workplace
situation um with the same people that
he was literally just heading to a
meeting in minutes afterwards um but
we'll have to say that's why it's
difficult to speculate at this point
okay well let's look at the may 10 event
uh specifically then 100 people were
invited to bring their own boos
and the invite was from the pm's private
secretary martin reynolds i think we can
actually look at that invite
um and then the prime minister said on
the 12th of january um that um
he didn't really
realize that when he was there that it
was some sort of party and he was there
for about 20 minutes in the garden 100
people had been invited to come along
and bring their own booze
and then he said subsequently he thought
that probably on reflection that he
should have told people to go back
inside um are you slightly anxious that
that could lead to another breach of the
law by the prime minister well i'm just
anxious that we get to the end of this
and we actually see all of the
information out uh in the whole i mean
martin reynolds has clearly gone from
number 10 now uh because i'm going to
stay
no no but this is a different situation
in terms of the fact that martin
reynolds actually went out and actively
invited people into it do you think he
did that without the prime minister um
he could easily have done that but but i
don't know um you know this is his
private secretary and he would have sent
out an invite to 100 people to party in
the garden of number 10 with booze
during the lockdown when nobody else was
allowed to meet even outside apart from
with one other person and the prime
minister wouldn't have known well i know
my private sector does things without me
now
i don't know this is all speculation so
i can't you're not throwing your private
sector under the bus then no no
absolutely because they you know
i'm not talking about drinks but i'm
clearly i do not sit and do the job of
my private sector otherwise there's no
point having a private sector right in
the middle of lockdown and 100 people
invited to bring their own booze in his
back garden yeah
and he was there for 20 minutes what i'm
saying what i'm saying is that what i'm
saying is that this invitation is is not
acceptable because clearly bringing
other people in from outside and i think
that was the different from the
situation we were just talking about
when the prime minister was just
literally heading to a meeting
but unless this is why speculation isn't
particularly helpful because until we've
got all of the information in front of
us then we can make a
a proper informed decision about it at
the moment we're just going around the
houses speculating okay but the prime
minister knew that he was in the garden
obviously he knew that he'd been in the
cabinet room and there had been cake
there and people including his interior
designer or decorator as we would call
them in wigan were there as well and yet
he would then also was potentially at
four other events that he's been linked
to and then he said this on the 1st of
december if you'll bear with me in the
house of commons at the dispatch mr
speaker
what i can tell the right honourable
gentlemen is that
is that all guidance was followed uh
completely during number 10. i have been
repeatedly assured
since these allegations emerged
that there was no party
and that
and that no
kovid rules were broken and that is what
i have been repeatedly assured
so that suggests that the prime minister
uh has been informed as you see with
this the second thing that he's been
informed okay fine these are people in
the workplace but in mind there's about
400 people working downhilling straight
it's a it's a workplace it's not um just
the home of the prime minister the home
of the chancellor
um and so there were a lot of people
around there all the time now clearly
where the investigation uh is looking at
why the police
would have
found a contravention is because the
fact that there were food alcohol these
kind of things are involved in that but
that's why we need but the prime
minister at the time
um when he spoke in parliament said
i believed this was actually a workplace
gathering um
he's now said that the police have
because they found otherwise in that
particular event that we're just
discussing um he respects that decision
um and has paid the fine i don't know
what he's saying i don't know what
you're trying to tell me though well
what i'm trying to say that the prime
minister had advice he just said he just
said that that um uh
he was told that he believed all
guidance was followed he thought all
guidance was followed now the police in
the event that they've investigated to
date um have said no
that wasn't the case he's accepted that
um that decision from the police he's
paid the fine um and and then he's
moving on does he accept that he broke
the law
he's accepted that the police have come
up with a different conclusion to where
where he
[Music]
thought at the time does he accept he
broke the law though except the police
have found him to have broken the law
yeah but does he accept well i don't
know again it's speculation because i
haven't spoken to him about it
do you accept that he broke the law
um well the police have found that
because the only other way of doing it
is to go to a court and contest the
fixed penalty notice and frankly that's
just not not that you know the system
that we have about fixed penalty notices
that's not really so given that you
accept that he broke the law why can you
still support him why can't why can a
sitting prime minister who is a law
breaker be a lawmaker because it's a you
know the you you're opening the the
prime minister interpreted what he
helped with at the time of the law the
guidance at the time um and so and and
that's what he did he take it he took
his decision in the heat of the moment
but he's accepted he's done wrong he's
accepted he's made a mistake he said any
he's made a full apology 30 times as you
as you say yesterday in this um
statement i don't think anyone could
really see that he didn't think that he
wasn't contrite i mean
he either didn't know what the law was
which is not acceptable or he broke the
law which is not acceptable well
the times reported that the the the
party that he was fight for the day
afterwards
no no but i'm saying so different so the
media who were covering at the time
didn't think anything of it they
probably didn't know about the other 16
events maybe not but actually the one
we're talking about whether he he knew
he was breaking the law or not well the
newspapers didn't really seem to worry
about the fact that he broke the law so
at the time we it's difficult to look at
hindsight about someone's mind what
someone's thinking about two years ago
when we are
than the police then i'm saying that
that that was the prevailing view at the
time was that the prime minister's
birthday he had a few minutes of respite
that was a prevailing view at the time
as reported in the newspapers but we're
now looking at with a very different
lens because of the situations that
that's come up and
that's what builds up to that uh that
anger that frustration that i know
people are feeling but that's why the
prime minister was right to accept the
fixed penalty notice to pay the fine to
apologize fully to parliament yesterday
on a number of occasions and then to
move on
okay let's just have a look at what the
ministerial code um says here we go
ministers who knowingly mislead
parliament would be expected to offer
their resignation to the prime minister
and of course he wrote the forward for
that as well you're saying he didn't i'm
saying what should happen
if a minister breaks the code
should they resign
if
someone breaks the ministerial code then
yeah that's that's the um expected thing
to do absolutely the right thing but
what you what you're quoting there is
that you knowingly misled parliament
that's exactly what i'm pointing at and
i've just i've just explained that in my
in my opinion for all the reasons i've
said i don't believe he did knowingly
miss lee palm yeah you see i want to put
this in my back pocket for when you come
back in a month's time and he's got more
convictions and then we talk we remind
ourselves again about well that's fine
no put it put in your back pocket
because as i say this is why it's
difficult to speculate because what we
are after what i'm after what every um
mp is after is the whole
information because we come on day in
day out to speak to you to speak to
other other new colleagues and really
happy to do so
with not all of the information and
that's part of the media center okay so
just oh that's interesting so you are as
frustrated as everybody else is in the
country to try to get to the bottom of
what happened
i want the sugray report so that we can
see everything i want to make sure that
police can get to there and the
investigation so we can finish that part
of it and then we can and then we can
probably move on because there's so many
issues um
we're not going to do that
and you um
presumably think that it's nonsense to
compare breaking a rule that you make
yourself when 120 000 people have died
and the country was in lockdown for uh
many many weeks to um receiving a
parking fine for parking on a double
yellow line i think if you put them to
put the two together is it difficult to
make a comparison i think what brandon
lucy's saying yesterday was the process
is actually very similar in terms of the
fact that uh you're not technically
found guilty you're technically not
convicted because that's done in a ju
in a court not by the police the police
enforce the law and so that's i think
the point that brandon was making rather
than actually just the juxtaposition of
parking and a covered transgression okay
thanks for clarifying that i appreciate
uh talking to you this morning thank you
for joining us much appreciated
well there'll be full coverage of prime
minister's questions from midday here on
sky news and a bit later on in the
programme i'm going to be speaking to
the interim u.s ambassador to the uk
that's philip t rica for a u.s
perspective on the war in ukraine and
much much more that's at half past eight
so do stay with us for more on that
well the pm's apology is making plenty
of this morning's front pages boris
johnson's latest partygate grilling by
mps in the commons the metro leads with
the prime minister's own words i'm truly
sorry
the guardian quotes kistama in the
debate labeling mr johnson a man without
shame
the eye leads with the comments by
former party chief whip mark harper that
mr johnson is not worthy of great office
the mirror looks ahead to thursday's
vote on whether the epm should face a
parliamentary inquiry listing the
reasons why it thinks he should and tell
story mps you choose
but according to the times those same
mps have already been ordered to block
any inquiry
the express however believes that this
is all a waste of time and there are
bigger issues to deal with
still to come this hour on the program
as russia begins to
its offensive in donbass i'll be
speaking to the former british
ambassador to ukraine lee turner about
president zielenski's next move
we'll head to the philippines and speak
to the telegraph's travel editor claire
oven as tourism chiefs meet there to
discuss how to help the sector recover
in the wake of kobit restrictions and
we'll be joined by labour's deputy
leader angela rainer as mps prepare to
vote on whether an investigation should
be launched into claims boris johnson
misled parliament
now the uk ministry of defense says
ukrainian forces have been able to repel
numerous russian assaults in the donbass
region in the countries east
it comes as the war enters what both
sides have described as a new phase with
major russian assaults beginning along a
front stretching more than 300 miles
from northeastern ukraine to the
country's southeast
the city of cremino with a population of
18 000 is one of the first to be
captured by russian troops with the
regional governor confirming ukrainian
troops had withdrawn
fighting continuing in the port city of
mariopol president zielenski saying the
situation there is extremely severe
battles have been fought at two separate
steelworks after days of resistance
russia took over iliac steel and iron
works but nearby the azov style steel
plant remains a ukrainian stronghold
well the deputy mayor of mario paul is
cautious of russia's offer of a
humanitarian corridor to allow people to
leave
me personally do not believe in any
trust or any words from russia and i'm
absolutely sure they
are not going to take their word
so
it would be good if they would allow
uh
civil citizens to live as often
territory or to leave the city but they
didn't allow this for 50 days why should
they allow this now
let's bring in deborah richard we're
standing by in kiev forest this morning
hello to you deborah um so the latest
situation as far as the east of ukraine
is concerned
from your perspective in kiev this
morning good morning
good morning yes there's actually been
some new information that's just emerged
comments from ukraine's deputy prime
minister saying that a preliminary
agreement has been reached with russia
to enable the evacuation of women
children and the elderly from mariupol
as the deputy mayor just said in the
clip you played though clearly trust
levels are incredibly low we've had on
many occasions attempts to create
humanitarian corridors for civilians
from mariupol from many other cities
that have just fallen apart and the
civilians have been caught and are still
suffering but that city is
it's been the site of the heaviest
bombardments by russian forces since the
beginning of the invasion it is the site
of the worst humanitarian suffering the
mayor of mario paul puts the figure of
dead in the city at more than twenty
thousand and it fully admits that that
figure could be a conservative estimate
so trying to help the remaining
civilians that thought they're thought
to number about a hundred thousand to
leave the city safely is a priority for
for ukraine but whether a humanitarian
corridor will actually emerge given the
number of times they failed that remains
to be seen and at the same time you have
this fierce standoff this final stand
taking place at these vast steel works
where you've got ukrainian forces still
holding out under intense russian
bombardment the russian ministry of
defense giving them yet again an
ultimatum to lay down their arms and
leave at two o'clock local time this
afternoon it probably won't happen
because it hasn't happened so far okay
thank you
jail putin critic alexei navalny claims
that russian troops killed a civilian in
ukraine simply because he happened to
share the same last name divali says
that soldiers took the life of a 60 year
old man in the town of butcher where
hundreds of civilians have been killed
sky news has been unable to verify these
claims
looking at some of today's other
headlines we netflix shares have fallen
after the streaming platform lost
subscribers for the first time in a
decade more than one and a half million
uk users cancel their subscription in
the first three months of 2022.
one person has been killed and 10
injured after police in sri lanka opened
fire at people protesting fuel price
increases the island nation is in the
midst of its worst economic crisis in
decades that has seen weeks of
anti-government demonstrations
a u.s congressman has called for travel
bans against six uk lawyers calling them
foreign enablers of russian oligarchs in
a letter to the secretary of state
anthony blinken steve cohen says the uk
has become the ideal place for powerful
russians to harass intimidate and abuse
the law
upcoming changes to the highway code
will mean owners of self-driving
vehicles will not be responsible for
crashes and will be allowed to watch tv
while behind the wheel the new code will
make it clear however that motorists
must be ready to take control of
vehicles when needed
harry assuring now prince harry has
opened up about seeing the queen for the
first time in two years saying he just
wanted to make sure that she is
protected in a sit-down interview with
nbc um with hoda kot to be aired in full
later this morning he said he now feels
like america is his home
maddie at buckingham palace for us this
morning hello to you mazzy um so i think
that the palace always used to set the
firm i always used to say never complain
never explain he's breaking all the
rules
good morning k yes and has done really
since um since he and megan stepped back
from royal life i mean we all remember
that infamous interview really bombshell
interview he gave to they gave together
to oprah um two years ago where they
accused the royal family of racism
against uh megan and frankly the royal
family will probably be relieved that
there so far hasn't been any equivalent
bombshell or disruption coming from this
interview this time harry gave the
interview alone he did it when he was in
the hague in the netherlands for the
invictus games and and the headline so
far seems to be that he um stopped off
with megan for a surprise visit for tea
with the queen at windsor castle they
said they wanted to um see that the
queen was protected and with the right
people around her and despite that
slightly cryptic comment and we know
that um harry and megan have had ten
that have been tensions between them and
other members of the royal household
despite that this will be seen as an
olive branch really this this reaching
out to the royal family obviously they
both missed um prince harry's
grandfather for prince philip's memorial
service last month this is the first
time we think that megan has been back
in the uk um in europe even since they
stepped back from royal life certainly
it's the first time they've been seen
together
so an olive branch so far we'll have to
see what else comes out of the interview
later today
maddie for now thank you
buckingham palace looking absolutely
stunning this morning let's tell you
about johnny depp should we he's given
evidence in court as part of a
multi-million dollar defamation case
against his former wife amber herd in
his first appearance on the stand he
accused hood of making up what he called
heinous and disturbing allegations
against him here's martha canner
with a skip and a salute one of
hollywood's most successful actors
arriving for perhaps the most important
performance of his life
with 150 million dollars in damages on
the line johnny depp told his side of
the story
but never
did i myself
reach the point of um
striking
misheard in any way
nor have i ever struck
any woman
in my life
depp said allegations he is a domestic
abuser are lies invoking the fairy tales
it's been six years of
trying times
it's very
strange when
one day your uh
cinderella so to speak and then in 0.6
seconds
quasimodo
under the steely stare of his former
wife depp acted out the point that women
can be the primary abuser
my mother
was quite unpredictable
she was very unpredictable
um she was a
she had the ability to be
as as cruel as
anyone can be
he spoke in detail about his own mum
betty sue being violent to her husband
and children including a young death
shield yourself because you didn't know
what was going to happen
much of this trial is he said she said
it's been an unedifying portrait of a
volatile relationship but with the
actors paul bettany and james franco
also listed as potential witnesses
alongside the tech billionaire elon musk
it is a case which will continue to
captivate
six years after johnny depp and amber
heard divorced the ruins of their
relationship continue to be picked over
in a courtroom whichever way this
seven-person jury sides both will be
diminished by the battle martha kellner
sky news virginia
now is perhaps best known for one of
rock and roll's most famous breakups but
liam gallagher has been opening up about
his health
[Music]
he's singing along at home aren't you i
know
i know that blasted thea drums didn't it
the former oasis star has said he needs
a hip replacement because of arthritis
he told mojo magazine he'd rather be in
pain than have an operation and joked
that his fiancee debbie guida could push
him around in a wheelchair
to start with the the time shows a
picturesque view of a multi-coloured
tulip field norfolk this is some of the
gorgeous stuff we can show you this
morning it will open to the public once
again tomorrow after visitors raised
thousands of pounds for the norfolk
hospice last year more than 6 000 people
attended
and talk about a glass act a set of art
deco car mascots have been put up for
sale by auctioneers at the mall
galleries in london the bi-annual la
lique auction there's posh includes all
29 car mascots designed by the french
jeweler renee lalique
and he has won for the constant commuter
the m6 has been voted britain's best
motorway by 32 of lorry drivers while
the m25 has come up second at 31
not sure how uh that um has happened um
you can't really ever uh avoid a jam can
you on the m25 but m6 32
of lorry drivers thinks that that is the
best motorway in the uk did you also
know trivial pursuit fact that it is
also the oldest motorway in the united
kingdom so then now
um
a woman narrowly escaped death after
fainting and falling under a train in
argentina cctv footage has emerged
showing the incident and her miraculous
survival
are the passengers
other passengers watched in shock as the
woman falls into the gap between the
train and the platform at the station
unbelievably she was pulled back to
safety and treated by medical staff
she's since been discharged from
hospital and says she doesn't remember a
thing probably just as well really isn't
it
looking at our top stories this morning
boris johnson is preparing to face zakir
stammer at prime minister's questions
following renewed calls for him to
resign for breaking copied rules
ukrainian forces have repelled advances
by russian invaders in the east but
president zielenski says the situation
in the southern port of mariopol is as
severe as possible
johnny depp has told the court that
amber hood's allegations of domestic
abuse are disturbing as he testified for
the first time in the libel trial
against his ex-wife
returning now to the war in ukraine
where russian forces have launched a
major new offensive in the country's
east
the operation has seen thousands of
russian troops repositioned to try to
seize the donbass the new focus of
vladimir putin's invasion
ukrainian positions have been battered
by heavy artillery including the village
of piske which borders the city of
donetsk from there our correspondent
mark stone has this report
we're just outside the russian-held city
of donetsk
the front in this war stretches more
than 300 miles
well we're just approaching the small
town of piske and it's right on the
front line the russian
soldiers a kilometer or two ahead of us
we're with a unit holding one tiny part
of a long line
dotted all along it are towns and
villages like
pesky not that there's much left of this
place anymore though
this is artillery
yes yes
this was home to two of the few
civilians who have held out here
two days ago it was hit one woman was
injured but she survived
nearby this is the very limit of the
ukrainian resistance the unit's platoon
commander is dennis godive first
position to enemy
about
there about
800 meters
in trenches from a different century
they have the simplest of weapons and a
few have the most sophisticated too so
this is a british weapon yeah it's
business weapon yeah
an anti-tank missile
weapon
yeah it's a
very good weapon for me each one of
these shoulder-fired missiles can take
out a russian tank
the mines too they hope will stop a
russian advance here but they can't stop
the artillery
no no no no no
it's normally oh look that all time
like i said all time now it's normally
here in the donbass the lines were drawn
many years ago since the russians took
crimea in 2014 this has been contested
but they're digging deeper this time
it's my life it's life my children my
kids my
mother
my wife and my people because i am
ukrainian
enemy won't
destroy my country not only cities
not killing people destroyed my nation
the russians have regrouped on the land
beyond all their forces are now
concentrated in this part of the country
we must change place okay
but this new offensive won't be quick
the assessment here is that these are
just preliminary strikes for a much
larger assault in the weeks ahead
some of the soldiers have been here
fighting and sleeping for the last year
tired and short of weapons but on their
own land up against an invader they
believe they will win
mark stone sky news in pesky ukraine
joining us now is the former british
ambassador to ukraine and that's lee
turner hello mr ambassador thank you so
much for joining us on the program this
morning we've seen what's happening to
the east of the country
is the western enough to help the
country that you once called home
we have this situation where the
russians are launching a major offensive
in the east of ukraine as your
correspondent was just saying there is
no sign of any russian breakthrough
and it's difficult to predict how the
war will go
we saw
at the beginning of the
war in on the 24th of february what
seemed like overwhelming rushing russian
forces not managing to break through
in many places and we're seeing it again
now where in theory the russians have
stronger forces but the ukrainians are
so far holding them back
now there are two
big things that the west can do
one is to continue to provide weapons
which it is doing in quite a grand scale
the ukrainians continue to ask for more
that's not surprising they're under
incredible pressure
but the west is doing quite a bit and
the uk
is playing an important role there in
providing anti-tank and anti-ship
missiles and perhaps some of these
armored vehicles we've been hearing
about
that's important because it looks as if
this is going to be a long drawn-out
conflict and what unless one side
unexpectedly collapses for one reason or
another
and it will be important to keep
supplying those weapons then the other
thing
is on the economic side we've been
hearing a lot about sanctions
which are certainly making life
difficult for russia and for the russian
elites in particular but there's a lot
more that could be done and the european
commission has been looking at the fact
that
the eu as a whole since the 24th of
february has paid
russia
20 billion euro for gas alone not to
mention oil which it also imports in a
grand scale from russia and the
commission has put forward some pretty
ambitious plans to reduce
that
purchase of gas by two-thirds within a
year
and that's
155 billion cubic meters hard to
conceptualize what that is but simply by
reducing their thermostats by one degree
you can cut usage of gas by 14 billion
euro over the next year so there's a lot
more that could be done and we should be
doing it
um a lot of my esteemed guests yesterday
morning mr ambassador were all pointing
out that we needed to make sure that
putin has an off-ramp how important is
it in your opinion that that is the case
it's essential to keep talking and to
try and keep open avenues to prevent
more deaths in this incredibly bloody
war
the ukrainian people have suffered
immensely
and are continuing to suffer hundreds of
people being killed as far as we can see
every day and of course the
russian families across the country are
losing their sons too although their
suffering is not comparable with what's
happening in ukraine and it is vital to
keep an off ramp the difficulty is that
it's
almost impossible to see any
resolution to this conflict which could
satisfy both sides
president putin who launched this war in
order to try and keep himself in power
and to stop any growth of democracy in
russia from a
different model operating and being
successful in ukraine
cannot accept or will find it very hard
to accept any outcome that doesn't give
russia more land than it had at the
beginning of this conflict and from the
ukrainian side when they've lost
so many of their people and suffered so
much
it's very difficult to see how they can
accept any offer that gives russia more
land than they had at the beginning
which rewards
the aggressor so although we must keep
looking for diplomatic resolutions
it's very difficult at the moment to see
anything else happening than a long
drawn-out conflict
and indeed in the earlier stages of this
conflict where russia was apparently
negotiating
many experts were quite skeptical about
whether they were really interested in a
resolution which ended in anything other
than the extermination of ukraine and
total victory for russia
how concerned are you
that um if it comes to it
that president putin may revert to a
nuclear option
it's very difficult to assess the
likelihood of that happening on the one
hand
nuclear weapons have not been used in
the world since 1945 so there is an
extraordinarily high threshold
which
means that any armed forces will think
not once not twice but three times
before ever
lowering the threshold under which
nuclear weapons are used so i would very
much hope that it will not happen
at the same time
it cannot be ruled out and if russia is
visibly losing this war
it it
could be that putin would authorize
their use there's a there's a subset of
whether the russian military commanders
would actually obey orders to use
nuclear weapons but unfortunately up to
now we've seen russian military
commanders doing all sorts of things
which
are reprehensible and have led to
enormous loss of life including
flattening all these cities around
ukraine and killing thousands of people
so i'm afraid we cannot completely rule
out the use of nuclear weapons tactical
nuclear weapons although i would hope
that that remains quite unlikely mr
ambassador we very much uh appreciate
you taking the time to join us on the
breakfast show this morning on sky thank
you
thank you
one of our top stories this morning of
course is what's going on as far as the
prime minister is concerned he
apologized 30 times yesterday at the
dispatch box for receiving a fine from
the police for party gate what's going
to happen next his minister
was here this morning to defend him
i think there's a number of um
procedures in place at the moment in
terms of the met police investigation is
still going on because there's other
events being investigated sugree has
been charged with uh publishing the full
report uh the the after having done her
interim report a few weeks ago and so
there's a number of um
streams of process already in in in
action but we'll see what happens with
the motion why doesn't he allow his
colleagues to look at somewhere if he's
got nothing to hide why not allow them
well they they will be able to see that
with we know from that sue grey report
they'll see that they'll see all the
detail there rather than setting up a
third strand of investigation but we'll
see what happens at um uh tomorrow in
the uh in the debate in parliament
tomorrow do you accept that he broke the
law
um well the police have found that
because the only other way of doing it
is to go to a court and contest the
fixed penalty notice and frankly that's
just not not that you know the system
that we have about fixed penalty notices
that's not really focused so given that
you accept that he broke the law why can
you still support him why kind of why
can a sitting prime minister who is a
law breaker be a lawmaker because it's
you know you you're opening the the
prime minister interpreted what he
helped with at the time of the law the
guidance at the time um and so and and
that's what he did he take it he took
his decision in the heat of the moment
but he's accepted he's done wrong he's
accepted he's made a mistake he said and
he's made a full apology 30 times as you
as you say
ali is here this morning thought sally
good morning morning i thought that
interview was fascinating because every
day we've seen ministers sort of
struggling to explicitly say that yes
the prime minister did break the law and
you heard paul scully there saying you
know that the alternative would have
been to go to court and contest the
fixed penalty notice he said this was a
decision that was made in the heat of
the moment i think they're trying to
portray what happened as a minor
misdemeanor but that obviously becomes
more difficult if the prime minister and
there is an expectation that he
potentially will get more fines that is
what could push mps over the edge but i
think a really interesting moment is
going to be tomorrow when labour are
pushing for this vote for an
investigation into whether he misled
parliament mps that have been quiet so
far are going to have to put their names
on the record tomorrow okay for now
thanks very much ellie thank you ali's
take at nine o'clock look forward to it
thanks so much indeed
now some social media influences are
pushing young people who are unsure
about their gender into making hasty
decisions around transitioning that's
the warning from a clinical psychologist
specialising in the area who is herself
transgender that woman is dr erica
anderson and she is with us now hello to
doctor thank you for joining us on the
program this morning um
you have been talking about people
experiencing a gender dysmorphia that
may say you're reducing the experiences
and perhaps not taking them seriously
with some of the comments that you're
making what would you say in response to
that good morning to you thank you for
joining us
good morning absolutely pleasure to be
here um can you can you just clarify
that you you said uh uh
you ask your question again please yes
of course um gender and so i'll be
specific if i may gender and social
roles are a very very sensitive topic
here in the united kingdom at the moment
as i'm sure they are where you are in
your part of the world as well um
what would you say to people who are
experian experiencing uh gender
dysmorphia that may say that some of the
views that you have voiced are perhaps
reducing their experiences or perhaps
not taking them seriously enough
well i take
seriously all the issues with
transgender people i want all
transgender people to get
the services that they need and i've
worked very hard in my career to
advocate for transgender people and
provided a lot of service to trans
people especially trans youth and their
families
and it's uh it's important that we
recognize what needs they have and we
address them
but you do am i writing sam i hope i'm
quoting you correctly here doctor you
say that rather than being transgender
some minors may be cycling through
identities and we should wait for that
to play its course
i have been saying that i'm concerned
that there may be a new group of
adolescents who are subject to some
influences that are very recent uh under
the uh pandemic
with the advent of uh increase in social
media and the influence thereof and uh
and so i've been seeing uh what i
consider to be perhaps a new cohort of
teenagers who
are uh exploring gender in to some to
some extent greater than uh previous
generations of teenagers the social
surveys in the u.s show that
quite a large proportion of teenagers
asserted a sexual or gender minority
identity and that a very large
proportion an unheard of proportion of
teenagers are suffering
from mental health problems
and so my concern is that some may be
looking to a gender identity different
than the sex assigned at birth as a
solution to their problems and they may
fall short because i'm not sure that
making a gender transition is going to
cure any mental health problems per se
i understand that what is your view on
medical interventions perhaps you could
explain to us also what the situation is
in the u.s as opposed to here in the uk
yes so i i have myself advocated for
gender affirming medicines puberty
blockers and hormones for a select group
of uh of young people but
the standard of practice requires a
careful evaluation a comprehensive
individualized biopsychosocial
evaluation and one of the concerns i've
been voicing is that not everywhere in
the united states is that kind of
careful individualized evaluation
occurring and so my hope is that we
would double down on the standards of
care
which are
published and that these standards would
be
observed and that by doing so we'll
provide the best care we can for every
child
and you also have some views on social
media influencers who could potentially
be swaying young people who are perhaps
not sure or clear on their path
are you suggesting that they should stop
doing that
i'm suggesting that some of the
influence from social media may be
deleterious in this regard in terms of
the identity formation of a young person
the social media companies themselves in
the us have conceded that their
algorithms and methods are designed
specifically to encourage
a repeated use and and more and more use
and one of the things that i've been
witness to and i hear from both young
people and their parents is that uh in
during the period of the pandemic quite
a large number of teenagers are relying
heavily upon social media for their
social outlet as opposed to in-person
contact at schools and in neighborhoods
which has historically happened for
teenagers
and there are some very unfortunate
things going on on the internet uh on
some of the platforms youtube and tiptop
there are a large uh proportion large
numbers of teenagers who are watching
content aimed at
persuading them about uh gender and
their gender identity and even giving
them advice about what they should do
about it and uh and then there are
further uh
indications from the use of uh of
certain platforms uh uh discord and and
others read it where there are subgroups
of young people who are who are uh
gathering together
and uh talking together about identities
and i'm concerned that this has had a
undue
influence on a lot of young people
okay absolutely fascinating to talk to
you um doctor we really appreciate you
staying up late over there in california
to um to speak to us fascinating stuff
hopefully we'll be able to speak to you
again soon thank you so much
my pleasure
good day
you too
well travel and tourism council global
summit is getting underway in manila in
the philippines as the sector looks at
how to recover in the wake of covid
restrictions the travel editor for the
telegraph claire owen joining us now
from milila lucky you thanks for joining
us uh claire good morning to you um
tell us about the philippines how are
they opening up after covid
well i mean tourism is so important to
the philippines um and its economy i
mean something like a fifth uh
pre-pandemic of its gdp came from
tourism so um to have that decimate over
the last two years has been um
fairly catastrophic and so um but in
order to build it and and they are
building it they've um
had a great recovery over the last year
and um
kind of halfway there to where they were
pandemic levels and they've done that
through a focus on vaccines primarily
not just the vaccine status of their
tourists and their visitors but the
vaccine status of their
their tourism staff so all um
tourism industry workers have to be
double vaxxed and they are currently
undergoing a um
well sorry
there we go you've been on the gym
already love
yet no
it's just a very excitable um windy day
today
right so um
yeah so they um yeah so the focus really
is on um on vaccine status and um
and just making sure that tourists feel
safe you know that there is that
confidence um that they know that
whoever they're dealing with has been
vaccinated there's a reduced risk if
they do catch covid
um
and and of course the focus on the
health protocols that we've all become
so familiar with over the past couple of
years of course there's always been
protocols in travel
and you know across the hotel industry
across the airlines but now um you know
i think there's more individual
recognition of the part we all have to
play in mitigating those risks and and
they're really focusing on that too and
you know the good news for them is as i
say there is an uplift um from
you know the rock bottom over pandemic
and of course you know the philip that
they're really focusing on their open
spaces huge open places um the fact that
their islands aren't over touristed and
you won't feel crowded
i have to say not necessarily the case
in manila but i don't think people
necessarily stay in malaya for too long
before they go off to
what all the islands have to offer
almost out of time claire sorry but i
just wanted to ask you very quickly
about sustainable tourism is that going
to catch on
well um the fact is
we're certainly seeing with our
subscribers that if the pent up demand
meeting the cost of living
crisis is is putting sustainability
quite low on their list of priorities
particularly if it adds a cost to their
holidays
at the um the conference is going to be
a really big focus on sustainability
it's one of the four key words um in
terms of the agenda so um which good
news because of course if if they don't
focus on
um
on sustainability the world that we're
so desperate to explore and this sort of
pent up demand to travel in it um isn't
going to mean much because the world's
going to look very differently so
yes in terms of industry big focus but
do
travelers care well unfortunately not as
much as they might have done previously
okay we must leave it there claire i
wish i was with you you've got the best
job in the world thanks very much indeed
for joining us enjoy manila thank you
thanks
thank you just want to leave you with
the images uh from manchester united and
liverpool uh fans yesterday supporting
applause
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the